viewers out there watching right now can
you describe the atmosphere back here oh
my god it's so crazy back here there's
so much happening there's so much press
we're all really nervous but excited and
I think that all of our adrenaline and
energy is feeding off of each other so I
think we all just really want to be on
that runway already and you know walk it
and work it and describe and talk about
how you know that fashion shows biggest
night is here in the fashion capital of
the world how does that make you feel
what does it mean to you I mean Paris
has been my favorite you know place in
the world for so long since I was a kid
and I think that fashion shows in Paris
are always crazy and everything but I
think this is definitely the biggest
thing it ever happened I think in Paris
and in the Grand Palais so it's I mean
very exciting for me because it's my
first vs show and to be here is amazing
and it's exciting and I can't wait to do
it let's talk about the performers this
evening Lady Gaga The Weeknd Bruno Mars
you excited to see all of that I'm
excited to see all of them I mean Gaga
is so incredible I think that she is
going to kill it her you know her rock
style is amazing and everybody loves a
good Gaga moment you know Abel is
amazing he's going to kill it the second
year so you know he already knows the
stage he knows what he's doing so I know
he's going to kill it and you try to
knock him off his game in a way a little
bit
I think he's good he's got it he you
know he's my best friend so we're not
uncomfortable with each other but he's
going to be awesome and Bruno I've never
seen Bruno perform but I mean I love his
new album and his songs are incredible
so I think he's powerful and he's
exciting and I'm walking during his
section also so it's going to be good
and I'm excited what will be your
Parisian victory meal after this is all
said and done what will you go to first
oh I'm already I already have my my
burger date we already you know rented
out a little restaurant and me Kenny and
Gigi and Lily and Joan and all of us
we're gonna go eat burgers already on my
cheeseburger ready so okay for you put
your roller ain't already free or but
our orders in last night we got 10
cheeseburgers and mac and cheese and
everything so we're excited awesome
this is the social media mecca right
here right now with all you women what
are the do's and don'ts in your book umm
do's and don'ts for what social media
hem like how many posts will you like I
mean today I can't count on I'm not
posting I'm probably gonna post a lot
and I'm sorry in advance but um I think
that I just like to post whatever I like
to post and you know I don't really
think about it I just do what I want to
do said what what emoji would the best
describe you right now oh well in
general it's probably the smilin double
horn little purple guy but right now
it's kind of this 2-mile guy with the
little nervous tear on top of his head
cuz i really know what's happening it's
kind of my face always gonna be finding
me so fun thank you selling your
Canadian fans out there can you blow
love you get it out